Basketball.
Since I was a kid,
I fell in love with this game.
And when I’m gliding through the air,
it’s like pressing mute on everything else.
Jace Carson has arrived.
New season! New level!
Get yo butt to school.
Love you, Momma.
Given all of your options,
you have to decide.
Do you want to be good at the next level
or do you want to be great?
At Cedar Cove Prep,
I expect you to be acutely mindful
and acutely prepared.
Not just on the hardwood, Mr. Carson.
Understood?
Understood.
Jace has got too much riding on his senior year.
We need to know he’s with someone who’ll watch his back.
You did say if I ever needed anything…
Swagger Prep on three!
One, two, three!
Swagger!
Something horrible stopped because
my best friend stepped up
and did something about it.
Unfortunately I don’t think it’ll be likely
that things will work out for him.
All the work you’ve done.
You’re so close and you put it all at risk!
I had to.
You could go to jail!
Jace, who else was with you that night?
Let’s go! Let’s go!
He attacked a man with the help of three others.
Everyone is watching.
Now is the time to stand with the kids.
Our school’s reputation is at stake!
I feel like I’m drowning.
Don’t let other people’s opinion…
Become my reality.
Come on!
The world ain't ready for what’s about to happen.
Not even close.